yesterday was a truly historic day
Donald Trump has become the third
president in the history of the United
States to be impeached and this came at
the conclusion of really almost 12 hours
of proceedings in the House of
Representatives including eight hours of
debate the House of Representatives
impeach the President of the United
States on two articles article one is
abuse of power article two is
obstruction of Congress now there are
both Republicans and some Democrats who
are pretending that this is no big deal
or they are skipping to he's going to be
acquitted in the Senate and not removed
therefore this entire thing was a waste
of time that couldn't be the more you
couldn't find a more incorrect place to
start our analysis of what took place
yesterday
so let's actually talk through it
because this is huge news only two
presidents before Donald Trump have ever
been impeached one in the 19th century
and another in the 20th century and now
we have Donald Trump president number
three in the 21st century this is very
rare Andrew Johnson was impeached in
1868 was impeached on eleven articles
including violating the tenure of office
act and Andrew Johnson was acquitted in
the eventual impeachment trial go to the
twentieth century
in 1998 Bill Clinton was impeached for
lying under oath and for obstruction of
justice related to a sexual harassment
lawsuit that was filed against him by
Paula Jones and related to Cliff Bill
Clinton's testimony denying a
relationship he had had with White House
intern Monica Lewinsky Bill Clinton was
also acquitted in the Senate impeachment
trial now Richard Nixon was not
impeached in the 1970s he would have
been and likely would have been
convicted but knowing this knowing that
the Republican public had turned against
Richard Nixon knowing that Republicans
in the Senate could no longer stand by
Richard Nixon knowing he would be
impeached and convicted he resigned on
August 9 1974
iconic moment in American political
history quick reminder of that on the
great issue the peace abroad and
prosperity without inflation at home
therefore I shall resign the presidency
effective at noon tomorrow Vice
President Ford will be sworn in as
president at that hour so a huge huge
deal even Nixon was not impeached but
resigned let's go to video from
yesterday last night we were streaming
at the time I think it must have been
about 8:00 8:15 p.m. Eastern Time a
video from the House of Representatives
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi
announcing the impeachment you will also
if you're watching notice her visibly
quiet the applause and cheering that
broke out from the Democratic side
clearly wanting not to make this seem
like something you would cheer about
because it is very serious quite frankly
here she is announcing article number
one impeachment of Donald Trump on this
vote the yeas are 232 nays are 197
present is one Article one is adopted
the question is on adoption of article
two and then very shortly thereafter
after a five minute plus a couple extra
minute vote on article two obstruction
of Congress Nancy Pelosi Speaker of the
House announcing that Donald Trump has
also been impeached on article number
two on this vote the yeas are 229 the
nays are 198 present is one article two
is adopted the votes were almost almost
along party lines 230 in total voting
for impeachment on article one because
of vacancies in the house instead of 218
to impeach they needed only 216 they got
230 on article two almost the same
numbers 229 voting to impeach one former
Republican who is now an independent
Justin Amash voted to impeach on both
counts
do you then had two Democrats Colin
Peterson of Minnesota who some know of
as a dino Democrat in name only Colin
Peterson of Minnesota not voting to
impeach Jefferson Vann drew of New
Jersey voting not to impeach and Vann
drew is this member who's made headlines
over the last few days he's expected to
switch from being a Democrat to a
Republican very very soon and then you
had jared golden of maine who split his
vote saying yes on article one no on
article two and that's why there were
230 votes in favor on article 1 only 229
votes in favor on article 2 then you had
a one individual who voted present and
that was there's this Hawaii
congresswoman she's running um
technically running for president Tulsi
Gabbard who is not seeking re-election
for her seat she took no position voting
merely present on both articles she said
quote I could not in good conscience
vote against impeachment because I
believe Donald Trump is guilty of
wrongdoing I also could not in good
conscience vote for impeachment because
removal of a sitting president must not
be the culmination of a partisan process
now what's complete nonsense about that
is that there's never an even split in
Congress between the parties so by
definition you have four
and 35 it's an odd number it's always a
partisan process in the sense that it's
led by one party and by that logic she
could never vote to impeach anyone now I
guess what she's saying is she would
have preferred the process involve more
Republicans but that's a completely
unrealistic expectation in the
hyper-partisan FoxNews era of politics I
don't want to waste too much time on
Tulsi Gabbard who cares what she does
okay she decided to just ride the middle
I do think it is yet another signal that
she may be planning a third party run
for president which could have its own
series of implications she'll be gone
for the house in January okay I don't
think I need to say too much more about
that now here is Trump talking back in
2008 with Wolf Blitzer
you know what took place yesterday was a
big deal it was carried out by serious
people Nancy Pelosi Speaker of the House
you had a Adam Schiff in the House
Intelligence Committee you had Jerry
Nadler in the House Judiciary Committee
these are serious people doing serious
work
here's video of Donald Trump back in
2008 telling Wolf Blitzer he finds Nancy
Pelosi impressive and would like to have
seen her actually do more on impeachment
in times past this is a classic video
instantly Nancy Pelosi the speaker well
you know when she first got in and was
named Speaker I met her and I'm very
impressed by her I think she's a very
impressive person I like her a lot but I
was surprised that she didn't do more in
terms of Bush and going after Bush it
was almost it just seemed like she was
gonna really look to impeach bush and
get him out of office which personally I
think would have been a wonderful thing
Beechum absolute for the war for the war
because of the contract he lied he got
us into the war with lies and I mean
look at the trouble Bill Clinton got
into with something that was totally
unimportant and they tried to impeach
him which was nonsense
and yet Bush got us into this horrible
war with lies by lying by saying they
had weapons of mass destruction by
saying all sorts of things
turned out not to be true so Nancy
Pelosi has done it and this is already
significant no matter what anybody tells
you this is a huge deal this is a
historic day now let's talk about the
next step the next step is a trial in
the Senate without regard to the likely
outcome of the Senate trial impeachment
is a serious constitutional
responsibility given to the House and
Senate and the house did its job and I
know that there are lots of people and
they're emailing me and tweeting me
saying Trump's going to be acquitted in
the Senate this is all a waste of time
the house is the house it has a role to
play in this process and it is to
determine whether articles of
impeachment are appropriate they did
their job now I agree with you the most
likely outcome of the trial in the
Senate is Trump being acquitted because
Republicans control the Senate and we'll
go through the math in a moment but you
sometimes just have to do the right
thing because it's the right thing to do
even if it won't have the immediate
effect that you might want imagine not
doing this and then Trump gets himself
reelected and then in five or ten years
you realize what why didn't I vote to
impeach it was the right thing to do it
might have prevented Trump from getting
reelected although it might not all
right we've calculated we were going to
lose in the Senate no that's not how we
do things Trump has been daring anyone
to hold him accountable and he's
basically not been held accountable he
has now been impeached and is one of
only three presidents in history to have
us suffered that fate it's the right
step even if he is not going to be
convicted in the Senate so let's now get
to the analysis of the Senate is it
possible that Donald Trump will be
convicted in the Senate sure it's
possible the math is you need two-thirds
support there's a hundred senators
two-thirds is 66 and two-thirds meaning
67 senators need to vote to convict in
order for the president to be removed we
have 45 Democrats in the Senate there
are two independents Bernie Sanders and
angus king who caucus with the Democrats
that's like 47 votes
probably for conviction Joe Manchin the
most concern
of Democratic senator might not vote to
convict we don't know but for our
purposes today let's assume we have 47
votes in the Senate that means you need
20 Republicans a Chris Murphy a senator
from Connecticut says he thinks that
there's about five Republican senators
that would consider voting for
conviction a bill weld former Republican
governor here in Massachusetts who's
running a pretty flimsy campaign but it
campaign nonetheless a primary campaign
against Donald Trump bill weld says he
thinks there's about five Republicans
that would consider voting to convict
that won't be enough even if that's true
it won't be enough so is it likely that
Trump will be convicted absolutely not
the Republican public and voters don't
want it Republican senators I don't
think would even really consider it
unfortunately unless the electorate
wanted it because it would be too
politically disadvantageous or at least
potentially risky but the idea would be
if Chris Murphy and bill weld are
correct if there are a handful of
Republicans willing to vote for
conviction maybe that would spread like
a virus and if you know I don't think
it's going to happen but if they decided
that there would be a secret ballot
where it wouldn't be known which
senators vote which way you might be
able to build enough momentum where you
get 20 Republicans that say let's
convict I think it is very unlikely if I
had to handicap it I would say it's a
roughly two to four percent chance that
something like that happens what are the
logistics of the trial number one when
will the trial be it's unclear because
it was presumably going to be in January
upon the return from holiday break but
we have just heard from Nancy Pelosi and
we'll deal with the story in full later
on in the program that she is going to
withhold the articles from the Senate
until such time that she believes there
will be what she considers to be a fair
hearing and a fair trial that may never
happen but the January date is now
certainly a question mark how long will
the impeachment trial last we don't know
it would generally be expected to run
somewhere between two and four weeks
will it be televised
I don't know um
I did a bunch of research on this today
and there is no hard and fast rule about
what has to happen it would be part of
the negotiations that the House
leadership would have with Senate
leadership as they move articles of
impeachment in that direction now
unfortunately Donald Trump will also get
a say because Mitch McConnell the Senate
Majority Leader has already said he will
be in total coordination with the White
House about how the impeachment trial
will be carried out that's not good will
this help Trump win in 2020 that is the
major political question if Trump is
convicted he's out and he will not be
reelected of course if Trump is
acquitted there are two ways that it
could go one is his acquittal is
successfully used as look at this
witch-hunt
I am a martyr I am the most unfairly
treated president in history which he's
been tweeting about and we'll get to
later and it reinvigorates his
supporters and increases right wing
voter turnout and Rockets him to
re-election that is a plausible and I
would say even realistic political risk
to this process the other would be if
the timing and the setup of impeachment
it gets delayed a little bit so it
starts overlapping with when we start
getting into the general election maybe
over the summer hypothetically if it is
televised if Trump is constantly going
crazy publicly if it becomes subject
matter of the debates between Donald
Trump in the eventual Democratic nominee
it could certainly end up hurting him
it's a question mark but there are major
political risks with this doesn't change
that it's the right thing to do
lastly would there be violence if Donald
Trump were convicted and removed I
believe that there would they on the
right the trumpets have been throwing
around terms like a civil war picking
sides and well you know we also heard
from that crazy Pastor Rick Wiles who
says that this is a Jew coup to remove
Donald Trump and eventually the military
will have to pick a side I sadly believe
there will be violence if Donald Trump
were to be convicted unimpeached and by
the way I think it's also quite
plausible that there will be violence if
Donald Trump loses the 20/20 election
but asserts that he didn't really lose
that it was stolen from him in some way
I I fear violence over the next year and
I hate to admit that let me know what
you think about the house vote the
Senate trial will get to a lot of these
sub stories including holding the
articles of impeachment for a while
before giving them over to the Senate in
the next few segments remember that on
January 1st we will have a 20/20 kickoff
membership fund drive and if you have
been thinking about supporting the show
I would particularly encourage you to do
it in an election year which is
typically when these shows grow the most
and get the most attention consider
getting on our mailing list at david
pakman.com sign up for our newsletter
and then in January 1st 2020 you'll get
an email with instructions on how to
sign up at an obscene sickening
disgusting discount you will be
disgusted at how big the discount is but
your credit and debit cards will be very
pleased with you quick break we'll be
right back after this